foreign
in the news lately you've obviously been
hearing a lot about Tyree Nichols and
police brutality if you've watched the
tape the police recordings the the body
cam recordings that have been released
um you know just how disgusting and
heart-wrenching the footage was
and there's been
the con in the in the conservative media
sphere one
is that it was terrible what took place
and then there's the other which is this
wouldn't have happened if he'd only
complied those cops did nothing wrong
we're going to play a little bit of both
here Jesse Waters a parent expert on
choke holds
oddly enough uh had this to say on Fox
News
Banning choke holds dealing with no
warrant searches uh dealing with
accreditation of police departments it's
necessary that we do all these things
but not sufficient typical Washington
politician the Memphis Police didn't use
a single Chokehold that entire time but
Democrats want to ban them a choke hold
done properly with a subdued Tyree and
had him handcuffed
one there were many cops
on top of literally on top of the 140
pound Tyree Nichols
large men of giant physical stature
couldn't get him under control is that
what you're saying Jesse Waters
and you know or maybe you don't because
you're a dum-dum but you know as well as
the rest of us that Senator Durbin from
Illinois was not talking about
legislation based on this specific case
he's talking about chokeholds and their
misuse in cases all across the country
year after year after year after year
it's not disingenuous to say there's all
of these elements in all of these cases
that we need to look at from a
legislative standpoint and maybe that's
one of the things we need to curb if it
didn't work in this particular case or
it wouldn't have affected this
particular case isn't the point
but it doesn't matter to Fox News are
you tired of the same old off-the-shelf
grocery store honey look no further than
manukora our sponsor the honey is made
by bees that pollinate the native Manuka
trees in the remote forests of New
Zealand it gives it a unique dark Rich
delicious flavor that you won't find in
any other honey it is 100 raw if you
look at it side by side with regular
boring honey you can see the difference
I've got my Honeys next to each other on
the counter and it looks very different
manukura is also responsible and
sustainable all manukura honey is
harvested using traditional methods so
you can enjoy your creamy caramel honey
knowing that the production was easy on
the bees and on the planet it's a
perfect natural sweetener I've been
adding it to my tea and my toast but
because of the amazing complex flavor I
find my self using it in things I didn't
even put honey in before like oatmeal
and yogurt and smoothies I have to admit
my girlfriend once caught me tasting
Manuka Honey right off the spoon because
it's that good it really stands out from
everyday honey so don't settle for the
ordinary honey when you can enjoy the
unique delicious flavor of manukora go
to manukora.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for a free pack of honey sticks
very nostalgic to when I was a kid with
your order a 15 value taste the
difference for yourself the link is down
below